[Musique]
Jean-Marie misant je suis sénateur de la
Moselle membres de la commission des
finances je suis très heureux de
présider cette mission d'informations
sur le bâti scolaire face à la
transition écologique le bâti scolaire
est représente une par importante du
bâti des collectivités puisqu'il
représente 50% de ce bâti donc c'est une
véritable source d'économie que de
travailler sur cette question pour
permettre aux collectivités d'avoir des
marges de manœuvre pour mieux dépenser
ailleurs cette mission d'information
elle a pour but d'évaluer les besoins de
rénovation du bâti scolaire lié à la
transition écologique de la maternelle
au lycée d'identifier les défis de cette
rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales et d'évaluer les besoins à
l'efficacité de l'accompagnement des
collectivités c'est aussi l'occasion
d'aborder la conception d'ensemble des
bâtiments scolaires mais également faire
un focus sur les projections
démographiques non seulement dans l'air
du temps mais ça répond à un besoin des
collectivités de manière générale des
gestionnaires publiques celui de
maîtriser la dépense d'énergie et de
consommer moins pour moins polluer et
donc c'est une préoccupation de tous les
instants et qui vraiment au coeur de
celle des collectivités de manière
générale nous espérons rendre
la production de nos réflexions pour la
fin du mois de juin c'est une mission
attendue par beaucoup d'opérateurs et je
forme le vœu que nous fassions
d'excellentes propositions